I'm loving this like American Pie
reunion meat but here's my question do
people still look up to you and say this
one time at Bank
yes they do what you lovely to be
associated with the movie people still
know but I have two daughters now and
when they're with me and they people
don't follow through hang the line I'm
like can we just stop there I'm not I
get really panicked well wait you have
kids like wait when it came out did your
kids see it no no my boy my daughter was
12 and so that that's a little early
that's that's a little early my son was
15 and he was going to come with us in
Los Angeles we went down for the
premiere of the movie and the night
before the premiere he he said he was on
the phone call with his friend back in
Toronto and they said well what's going
on he said well I'm going to the
premiere of American Pie tomorrow night
with my folks and the friend said oh
don't see it with your foe don't see it
with your folks don't want to see this
with your folks so he came to us and
said you know what I think I'm not gonna
go tomorrow and I'll see it when I go
back to Toronto with my friends and I
said I thought oh well okay it's gonna
be a big night meanwhile we went to the
premiere saw the movie I'm so glad he
wasn't
[Applause]
funny is we go back like 17 years you're
at the Idol finale I was funny because
my husband was working on TV show angel
at the time and I love angel he was
supposed to work but he happened to be
chopping a chopping cutting flowers but
with a knife which is dumb and he slit
his wrists luckily it was okay he just
had some stitches or whatever but they
gave him the day off and I was like
great you can come to American Idol with
me but when he went to work the next day
they were like you faked an injury just
to go see America we had to show the
stitches but because of that clapping
shot we I'm gonna tell you it's so funny
but when I found this out I was like we
didn't really know that it was that big
we were in a bubble right so we didn't
know there were like there were a lot of
celebrities there like for us I'm from
like a small town in Texas I was like
who's here and like there was certain
you know weed out it was a crazy thing
it was just a narrative this was also
there I know I know
yeah we were balling it was
and now I hear her awesome neighbors we
both live near each other why we should
become best friend I am down then you
could we could like borrow sugar yes so
what would I know your house
well you might like because I over
decorate for Halloween and and furs you
giant cats in your front yard
no oh I do know that person but know
that me for Halloween my family we named
them yeah for Halloween I decorated the
gate as as Frankenstein and Bride of
Frankenstein okay I'm gonna go cruising
your neighborhood yeah I do I love
decorating as well you're crafty I hear
is well-crafted yeah like just I it's my
happy space it's fun I got on music I
think so yeah I'm over forget the sugar
okay forget it
come let's fast yes and you know my
daughter's probably almost old enough to
like babysit your kids see in it like
you know even if she's yeah I'll let her
watch them
[Applause]
crafting you have like a place we have a
guest house that I've taken over and
turned into the craft house I did that
two hours for a minute and then I had no
days off and thus I was like well this
is useless but but I did that with arts
- yeah and I says no loses it no it's
smart because then it like keeps guests
away yeah before you go to break tell us
about the series outmatch that's when
your ass so um Jason Biggs has a new
show I guess I was very more community
and Eddie Kate Thomas and I are gonna be
on Jason show so it really is everything
[Applause]
plays a part of a parent duo that has
like I think show yet um four kids and
what like most of them are geniuses and
one isn't but they're just like trying
to keep up with how smart their children
are oh my god and then the one kid is
like you know just I'm creative
[Laughter]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going